У парламенті президенту України Петру Порошенку довго не давали виступити.
Через низькі, згідно з опитуваннями, шанси очільника держави на переобрання,
його запідозрили в намаганні вплинути
на майбутні президентські вибори або перенести їх.
Ця збанкрутіла влада, політично збанкрутіла,
яка хоче використати війну, для того, щоб себе зберегти
на посаді і не йти на вибори в тому числі.
І поставити під ризик
і під величезний тиск все суспільство.
Але після запевнення, що дата виборів президента -
31 березня - залишиться незмінною -
воєнний стан був все-таки схвалений Верховною Радою.
Це дасть можливість Києву проводити мобілізацію резервістів,
зміцнювати оборону та інформаційну безпеку,
наполягають депутати від БПП. Та додають:
обмеження свободи слова чи мітингів,
а також інші надзвичайні заходи, зокрема економічні,
насправді запроваджуватися не будуть.
Чому вони можуть обмежувати права людей?
Це не обов’язково трапиться. Але  якщо агресивні дії
на території України будуть відбуватись,
то нам треба дати дієвий механізм для превентивних
протидійних заходів, зокрема, введення комендантської години,
перевірки паспортів, документів, що встановлюють особу,
можливим розквартируванням військових,
можливо мобілізацію транспортних засобів.
Воєнний стан в Україні не оголошувався ще жодного разу
з початку конфлікту в 2014 році,
хоча ситуація була набагато критичнішою, ніж зараз.
Європейським експертам незрозуміло,
як ці заходи посилять оборону країни.
Я вважаю, що проголошення воєнного стану
швидше пов'язано з внутрішньою політикою, ніж з зовнішньою.
Порошенко хоче показати, що він
як верховний головнокомандувач може реагувати, причому жорстко.
Рішення Порошенка скоротити термін воєнного стану
до 30 днів заспокоїло експертів.
Як передбачається, дата виборів буде підтверджена в грудні.
Однак якщо воєнний стан продовжать,
то вибори доведеться перенести.
На тлі ухвалення Верховною Радою рішення про воєнний стан в Україні,
з'явився страх, що конфлікт з Росією спалахне з новою силою.
Відповідальність за те, що трапилося, Захід покладає на Росію.
В МЗС Австрії вперше заявили про можливість введення нових санкцій щодо Москви.
Тим часом, канцлерка ФРН Анґела Меркель
ще напередодні провела телефонні переговори як з Путіним,
так і з Порошенком, наголосивши на необхідності деескалації конфлікту.